do zinc sunscreens really stop working
and turn toxic after two hours this is a
new study that was published a few days
ago you can see their very scary looking
graphic abstract here you can see uva
leaves and it becomes toxic the
non-leaves but the study only found that
this happened with uncoated zinc oxide
and chemical sunscreens containing
avobenzo the avobenzone is reacting with
the zinc oxide the avobenzone is
breaking down avobenzone is a uva
absorber which is why the uva protection
is going down and supposedly whatever it
breaks down to is the toxic stuff but
this is a new information we've known
this for about 20 years which is why we
have coated zinc oxide any responsible
sunscreen maker who's using both zinc
oxide and avobenzone will use coated so
this isn't a concern in your sunscreen
unless you're using an extremely dodgy
sunscreen in which case you probably
have other things to worry about as well
this could be a concern if you're
layering chemical and physical
sunscreens but i've told you before not
to do that because of this specific
problem also the toxicity part was done
on zebrafish embryos which we are not oh
that's actually kind of cute look at
these little dudes